I think the main ball in the Middle East
is in fact Iran it's an imperial power
we ought to worry about Isis we ought to
worry about al-qaeda but the big flick
is Iran and its ability to move forward
and dominate more and more of the Middle
East therefore holding them back from a
nuclear weapon is in fact an extremely
important strategic construct you know
Admiral it's such a complicated
situation on the ground we are lined up
against Iran and Yemen we seem to be on
the same side in Iraq and we are against
them again in Syria you could say I just
want to read you something quickly that
the Foreign Minister of the Islamic
Republic of Iran Mohammad Javad Zarif
who is in Lausanne wrote in foreign
affairs he said quote as a responsible
regional power Ron will actively
participate in combatting and containing
extremism and violence through bilateral
regional and multilateral cooperation
with countries in the region and beyond
sounds great right my question for you
is is Iran can't Iran be a military
partner in the Middle East I don't think
so at this point that's decades away if
it ever arrives what Iran is all about
is dominating capitals in the region
today Iran effectively runs five
capitals around the region and they're
going to continue to push and it's all
part of this Sunni Shia war that's going
on our number one thing in addition to
holding Iran off is to reassure our
allies in the region Israel the Sunni
states of Saudi Arabia the Gulf states
Egypt that's where we are putting our
focus not on trying to find the chimera
of cooperation with Iran Admiral you say
the most important thing is prevents
Iran from getting a nuclear weapon I'll
put John Kerry's own question back to
you if not through talks then how if if
the question is if talks fail what do we
do I think a we continue the sanctions
and B we go after the program with
unconventional means
so that's cyber unmanned vehicles
special forces there's a variety of
things we can do short of an all-out war
in the Middle East I think that's
probably where plan B
do we have the legal platform to define
and declare this kind of low-grade cyber
plus special ops war I think we do I
think we look at this and again I'm the
Dean at the Fletcher School of
International Law and Diplomacy we look
a lot at the laws of war and the ability
to go after and preempt a clear and
excellent threat I think given the
statements of Iran and how they would
intend to use a nuclear weapon I think
there's a clear case to be made Admiral
is the fact that it is taking so long
hardening or you do have more hope that
we will in fact get a deal or are you
becoming increasingly skeptical well I
think first of all we on our side and
it's not just the u.s. it's the p5 plus
one so it's kind of the West plus Russia
and China are all involved I think parts
of our side are emotionally involved in
this and that's always a bad thing in a
negotiation you never want to show the
opposite side that you're unwilling to
walk away from it our negotiators look
tired and tattered I think that we are
actually at a point where it's unlikely
to me we're going to get in accord and
that's unfortunate we ought to be able
to push this deadline if we need to to
go forward